[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we'll have the latest on
those riots in Minneapolis last night
and yes they were in fact riots no
matter what they're telling you on the
other channels that's a fact and we have
the tape
but first tonight we're gonna state the
obvious Donald Trump tweets an awful lot
many wish he didn't do it he does it
anyway it's often his preferred mode of
communication now whether or not it's
politically wise for him to do this
Donald Trump is an absolute right as an
American to express what he actually
thinks even if every other person on
earth disagrees with him when they used
to tell you this was a free country and
they often said that that's what they
were talking about the freedom of speech
well sadly it's become a much less free
country recently power has become
radically concentrated in far fewer
hands that at any time in the past 100
years at least and the people who wield
that power have no interest whatsoever
in your right to say something they
disagree with in fact they're delighted
to silence you if you try they're not
embarrassed to admit that they do this
they don't pretend anymore Twitter for
example now openly purges users whose
political views their executives don't
like it's bewildering if you think about
it that they're allowed to do this
because like all the big tech companies
Twitter only exists its CEO is only a
billionaire because Twitter enjoys key
exemptions from federal law exemptions
that you don't enjoy and we don't enjoy
here at Fox News it has those exemptions
because Congress carved them out for the
big tech companies and that means
Congress has the power to defend your
free speech online the White House does
too and yet they've done absolutely
nothing so far to help you until
yesterday Twitter returned the favor by
leaving the commander-in-chief's Twitter
feed alone and then Trump criticized
mail-in voting the president tweeted
that mail-in ballots could be quote
substantially fraudulent well as a
factual matter that is true and we can
prove it as we told you last night
mailing ballots have been linked to
numerous cases of election fraud people
have been criminally convicted for it so
it's really not up for debate
but this is an election year and mail-in
voting is now the central objective of
the Democratic Party and so you're not
supposed to know any of that
yesterday Twitter placed a so called
fact check on the
presidents tweet quote Trunk falsely
claimed that mail-in ballots would lead
to a rigged election Twitter announced
fact checkers say there is no evidence
that mail-in ballots are linked to voter
fraud and quote now get as a factual
matter that is a lie there's no other
way to interpret it but worse than a lie
it is a form of political censorship so
who decided to do this to censor it well
your Roth has the Orwellian title head
of site integrity at Twitter an irony
free zone when they don't understand
that their titles alone are scary that
means he's one of the company's censors
not surprisingly Roth is a political
activist and not an especially subtle
one in January 2017 Roth compared
Kellyanne Conway to the Nazi
propagandist Joseph gurbles that same
day he referred to the president's new
staff just moving into the White House
as actual Nazis and a lot more you can
look up his Twitter feed if you want
assuming he hasn't pulled it down by now
so these are the people controlling what
you're now allowed to think and say in
America they're authoritarians if
they're willing to censor the president
they will think of nothing at all of
silencing you and they don't they gladly
do it and no one pushes back
traditionally that role the role of
pushing back hard against censorship was
reserved for reporters their job was to
safeguard the First Amendment which is
designed to protect the weak not the
strong the weak are protected by the
freedom of speech and journalists are
supposed to care about the weak about
the public their readers and viewers
they weren't supposed to be simply thugs
hired to protect the powerful but that's
what they become watch Don Lemon of CNN
who in his defense often has no idea
what he's saying try to bully Twitter
into censoring ideas the authorities
don't care for shorter wouldn't remove
those tweets and they wouldn't come on
the show to talk about their decision to
let this disgusting smear stand people
have been removed from Twitter for far
less outrageous behavior come on Jack
Dorsey stop hiding behind the First
Amendment and it for profit stop doing
it do
the right thing stop hiding behind the
First Amendment says Donilon in the
annals of cable news that must be the
most unintentionally hilarious line ever
uttered by a script reader as if
exercising your god-given inborn right
to speech and thought and conscience is
somehow wrong it's immoral Don Lemon
demands that you stop thinking for
yourself fall in line get on board
obey tow the party line or we'll hurt
you that's his message and it's the
mirror image of what journalists should
be saying the only reason we have a free
press there's only one and that's to
fight back against authoritarian power
structures that demand we read from
approved scripts and now CNN is reading
those scripts it's terrifying and all of
a sudden it's everywhere throughout
April and May YouTube part of Google
took down any video that quote
explicitly disputes the efficacy of
global or local Health Authority
recommended guidance if you dared to
question the decrees of the politicians
some of whom are impressive and wise
many of whom are dumb and making it up
as they go along but if you criticize
them you were censored and many were
censored for doing that
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg recently
explained why censorship isn't really
bad in fact it saves lives if
information if someone's spreading
something that clicks people an imminent
risk of physical harm then we take that
down we don't allow that on Facebook
there are also other misinformation that
may not lead to physical Ament risk of
physical harm but still isn't the type
of stuff we want to be spreading through
our system so this month Facebook
announced that it's expanding this
effort it announced the first twenty
members of its new oversight panel that
panel will help decide which ideas can
be expressed in public and which ideas
must be thrown into the fireplace and
forgotten forever and you can imagine
who's on the panel it's a list of
political activists and aggressive
opponents of free speech Stanford Law
Professor Pamela Carlin headlines the
group pamela Carly look her up when you
have a minute what do you think she
cares about more safeguarding your
sacred constitutional rights or keeping
Donald Trump from getting reelected in
the fall that's a rhetorical question by
the way you know the answer